oh
[Applause]
is your speed underwater unmatched
does your breaststroke leave your
opponents in last place
maybe you're ready for a different
challenge
so what if you jumped into
a pool full of honey would you sink
to the bottom could you eat
during your swim and
is honey just bee spit
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you jumped into a pool full of honey
in 2005 professor edward
custler received the egg nobel prize
for comparing swimming speeds in syrup
versus water he found that
although the syrup was denser than water
the swimmer's increased motion made the
liquid
more viscous or flow more easily
so as the swimmers kept moving the syrup
became
just as easy to swim through as water
but if you stop moving and the honey
thickens
could you drown made from nectar
honey is the result of tireless work and
millions of flowers each bee
collects nectar from flowers and stores
it
inside its extra stomach known as its
crop after it mixes with
enzymes inside the bee the new chemical
is ready for long-term storage so
when it returns to the hive the bee
regurgitates the fluid
into another bee's mouth and that bee
passes it on to another bee creating
a daisy chain of partially digested
nectar
this process continues until one bead
deposits the fluid into a honeycomb
after the water has evaporated bees
seal the comb with a secretion from
their abdomens
which hardens into beeswax
so if you want to fill an olympic-sized
pool
how much honey would you need well
the pool would hold about 3419
liters of water so you'd need about 4.35
million kilograms of honey and
considering that one bee colony produces
27
to 45 kilograms of honey per year
this pool would contain many colonies
lifetimes of work honey
is a non-newtonian fluid a term named
after
the famous physicist sir isaac newton
you know the apple and gravity guy
he found that normal fluids like water
have a constant flow with no resistance
or viscosity
we call those newtonian fluids but
we're dealing with honey as a
non-newtonian fluid
its viscosity changes when you apply
force to it
such as the impact of you swimming in it
and the thicker the liquid the higher
the viscosity
centipoise measures the amount of force
needed to move a layer of liquid
in relation to another liquid on a mild
21 degree day honey has a viscosity
of 10 000 centipoise but
water is just one centipoise
oh and honey is one and a half times
denser than water too but honey
is also a thixotropic fluid which
means if it stays still it becomes a
gel-like substance
so that could slow you down if you want
an
easier swim through honey you'll need a
warm day
while your cannonball wouldn't have the
same splash as in water
the sudden movements of your arms and
legs would begin to change
the honey's composition and since the
buoyant force
increases with density you may float
back to the top after you jump in
so that makes it less likely that you'll
drown
professor cussler's experiment showed
that form drag
is the key to human swimming your form
or shape affects the drag on your body
when you're moving through a fluid
like swimming through honey streamlined
shapes
have less drag when they move through
fluids and
since we're all shaped differently the
drag you create in the honey is
unique to you no judgment here
you might want to break out your cap and
speed a bathing suit to
lessen the resistance while you swim and
you may even have a snack between laps
you'll get more than a mouthful of honey
while you're swimming
but take it easy if you eat too much
you could get sick while honey has been
used
to treat everything from coughs to
wounds
consuming too much could cause health
problems
considering the recommended daily
allowance of honey
is 10 of your daily calories
all this added sugar pouring into your
body could make you queasy
and even more dangerous every gulp
comes with the threat of botulism a kind
of food poisoning
these spores grow in improperly
preserved food and
create a toxin that attacks the body's
nerves
they can weaken the muscles you use for
breathing
and even kill you but there are some
benefits
one dip might leave you sticky but if
you make this swim
part of your morning routine your skin
could become
softer and well moisturized your
abrasions would heal faster and
you'd have fewer fungal infections
this tasty gel-like fluid has
just as many restorative properties as
it does drawbacks
used in moderation it could help your
body
inside and out but if you
swim in honey too often it might cancel
the healthy benefits
of course without honeybees we wouldn't
have the option of
floating in this sticky stuff it makes
you wonder
what if insects disappeared from the
planet
well that's a story for another
what if
you